there's little comfort in war but some
people are doing all they can
for a third day ukrainian forces
evacuate people from irpin on the
outskirts of ukraine's capital kiev it's
a precarious journey russian shelling is
never very far away
european has been constantly shelled
they are planes bombing russian soldiers
at home there is no electricity or light
no heating and the temperature is going
down we had to go
we hate putin and russia so much we hope
the war will be over soon
people are also fleeing sumi east of
kiev after russia and ukraine agreed on
a temporary ceasefire in the area days
of russian shelling have flattened parts
of the city this is what is left after
an overnight attack killed more than 20
people including children in their homes
moscow is offered once again to evacuate
people from a number of other cities but
only if they go to russia or belarus for
ukraine's president it is a proposition
steeped in cynicism
they ensure that a small corridor to the
occupied territory is open for a few
dozen people not so much to russia but
to the propagandists directly to the
television cameras so they can say this
is who saves people just cynicism just
propaganda nothing more russia's
military says this video shows its tanks
near kiev in the city people are scared
daily life has moved underground
intense times the vulnerable often
suffer the most every day more children
arrive at this orphanage from different
parts of ukraine svetlana tells me the
invasion adds another painful layer to
already difficult childhoods
the first group that arrived here was
from lisa chance there were many very
young kids among them they were
traumatized anxious when the sirens
sounded they would get really scared
the children have been brought here to
escape the russian shelling and the
fighting but some of them were already
victims of war
these children are from eastern ukraine
where a war against russian-backed
separatists started eight years ago
young lives that have never known a
world without conflict
nastia is from kiev a typical teenager
living in untypical times
my sister and i couldn't sleep at night
we lived in an apartment that was
bombing all the time so we took an
evacuation train to here
solidarity seems to be everywhere in
ukraine as does defiance protesters in
the southern city of chaplinka tell
russian soldiers to go away
[Music]
people want the conflict to end they
want the killing to stop families are
being shattered futures lost ukrainians
wonder how many soldiers will sacrifice
their lives for a war no one here wanted
natasha butler al jazeera lev ukraine